this month the spectator becomes the
first magazine in history to print
10,000 issues and we'd like to celebrate
with you subscribe to The Spectator for
12 weeks for just 12 pounds plus we'll
send you a bottle of commemorative
spectator gin absolutely free go to
spectator code at UK forward slash
celebrate
welcome to a rather a difference edition
of The Spectator a podcast I'm Fraser
Nelson editor of The Spectator and we
always think that each issue of the
magazine
tends to be shared around by about three
or four other people subscribers quite
often give it to their friends and
family and that's going to be a little
bit trickier now the we're in lockdown
so we were thinking how do we get the
columns the articles that people might
be missing about their family might have
been passing onto them before and we
came up with the idea of this podcast so
we've asked three of our economists to
read their articles out loud I'm
delighted to say that we've got Matthew
Paris liner Shriver and Isabel Hardman
first off is Matthew Paris on why we
should not consider this to be a war
shut up don't you know there's a war on
strong hints of that attitude have
emerged in recent weeks and the hints
are getting stronger the attitude is
mistaken the right answer to any inquiry
about whether we know there's a war on
is that there isn't a war on nobody with
sensible questions to ask about the
current strategy or its implementation
should be abashed to ask them Hitler's
spies are not listening Lord haw-haw
will not be broadcasting them and a
grown-up citizenry does not confuse
intelligent questioning with unpatriotic
breaking of the ranks no doubt some
questions will be misplaced some will
have easy answers and a few may hit home
so courtesy is needed and we must start
from the assumption that everybody is
doing their best but critical scrutiny
has seldom been more necessary
comparisons with the Second World War
are preposterous we face no existential
threat as a nation no fascist dictator
is trying to take over the planet nobody
is trying to exterminate an entire race
of people it's important to remind
ourselves that for instance ventilators
about which everybody is now talking are
a relatively recent medic
advanced and more generally that our era
is keeping alive
millions more old people but in very
very fragile health with this inevitably
comes heightened susceptibility every
death is a personal tragedy but figures
do matter it worries me that bald media
reports have say 2,000 deaths so far
tend to land on the public imagination
as might reports of a terrific train
crash like some kind of awful incident
rather than a shift in the cause of
deaths that in many cases were already
imminent my darling mother died last
night as I write this she was 93 and
covered 19 was not allowed to get her so
other things did her passing was
peaceful timely and quick and if I'm
able to avoid descending into more Koosh
nests over the death of someone who had
been the dearest person in the world to
me
then I shall dare risk unsentimental 'ti
in observing the passing of others too
we need to get this into proportion too
much time is now chasing too few new
facts one sympathizes with editors and
broadcasters it can't be easy but we're
slipping into a general media response
that badly needs calming politicians and
public health authorities are being
invited into studios to make statements
have you anything to tell the nation sir
rather than answer serious questions
broadcasters and journalists are filling
the air with frightening or moving
personal stories which are essentially
anecdotal with little indication of how
representative they are a friend who's a
junior doctor in the public health
sector answers might texted inquiry with
the news that in the General Hospital in
the large town where she works there
really isn't a problem or not thus far I
have yet to hear any health professional
interviewed whose story is that they are
not facing an avalanche now is it that
such witnesses do not exist or is it
that they are uninteresting to broadcast
my doctor friends other remark I simply
quote her was that the arrogance of
doctors is becoming insufferable and
years of uncritical adulation of the NHS
now threatened I heard on the Today
programme a specialist in palliative
care say with a catch in her voice that
she was having to confront patients with
a choice whether to die at home or in
hospital I should have wished gently to
have asked her whether this isn't a
question that often has to be asked in
palliative care she might well have been
able to explain but her remark was left
to go unchallenged I heard a doctor
lamenting probably with reason the
shortage of personal protective
equipment and explaining that sweaty
victims of the virus were touching her
Hospital Blues yet she had to wear the
same blues unchanged for a whole day but
how should she change after each patient
how often again she may have had a good
answer but nobody asked last Sunday on
BBC Radio 4 I heard a senior medical
officer from Scotland
tell her interviewer or appear to not
only that testing was not available for
those without symptoms but that it
couldn't or shouldn't be what did she
mean I wanted to ask are we perhaps into
a realm of broadcasting where generalist
presenters are simply unequipped to
drill down into the answers they receive
from experts an impression arises that
all the experts agree
so we laymen needn't bother our heads
with details but I have the distinct
impression that beneath an almost
priestly air of consensual expertise
real difference is seed we do ourselves
down by putting the experts on a
pedestal calling it the science and
saying we must obey it we end up wiping
away the doubts and debates that inform
the actual science shouldn't we hear
professionals debate each other should
medical and statistical correspondents
perhaps be doing the questioning
nor is this want of forensic
interviewing restricted to medical
science how is it that a line of some
350 billion pounds credit has become
available to us when every previous
chancellor has insisted that we're skint
can every country do this is there no
limit it's all very well asking rishi
sunic what more he's going to do for the
self-employed but I want to know who's
going to pay the money back and when
finally this estimates of how many made
I have swung between half a million and
five thousand assuming we end up much
closer to the latter the experts will
insist and perhaps rightly but it's
because we took their advice on self
isolation etc but good scientists know
the work of circle popper whose
contribution to the philosophy of
science was that no scientific
hypothesis deserves the name unless
capable of being falsified so what level
of fatalities or what contrary evidence
from countries that decided not to wreck
their economies would count as
falsifying the assertion that it was the
British lockdown that saved us I simply
ask in due course a science of Medicine
worthy of the name should be able to
answer that was Matthew Parris now
Lionel Shriver whose novel the mandibles
rather predicted locked down in a
depressingly accurate way we're anything
but safe by Lionel Shriver comically
Chinese Communist Party officials have
speculated that kovat 19 was planted by
the US Army yet a respectable conspiracy
theorists would deduce that a virus
sending the rest of the world into an
hysterical wholesale economic shutdown
has made in China written all over it
after all China didn't flatline its
entire economy to contain the contagion
at the end of this debacle then China
could rule the world although it won't
have many solvent customers left to buy
its product
the only other countries calling the
shots in future could be South Korea
Japan and Sweden having thus far
resisted the stampede to lock down in my
1994 novel gain control a rogue
demographer named Calvin Piper attempts
to design a virus that will kill two
billion people overnight thereby
arresting runaway population growth I
don't imagine my friend Calvin would
think much of kovat 19 in his quest for
a seriously nasty bug I bet he'd pour a
vial of the new corona virus right down
the sink for as fatalities are broadcast
even for Italy and Spain I shout at the
TV
these numbers are ridiculously low if a
headline ran tomorrow
British deaths in 2020 to reach 600,000
we could expect widespread popular
anxiety likewise the forecast global
deaths to exceed fifty eight million by
years and could drive governments to yet
more draconian measures to defeat this
plague but 600,000 Britons did die last
year and so did more than 58 million
people worldwide
we're under aware of it but scads of
people are dying around us all the time
hate to break it to you but we're mortal
we've been through alarmist projections
of viral mortality before and I don't
mean just SARS or MERS but HIV
researching gained control in 1990 I
tracked down all seven studies than
available that modelled the impact of
AIDS on population growth in Africa
where the epidemic was exploding for all
offered by epidemiologists predicted
that HIV would devastate African
populations whose growth would plunge to
the negative three authored by
demographers predicted that HIV would
have a negligible effect on the
continents population whose numbers
would continue to soar 30 years later
guess who was right we live in factional
times so scientists and commentators are
dividing into kovat camps
though aligned with a smaller skeptics
crowd can be dangerous
some contrarians are getting death
threats it even the establishment
Imperial College London has reduced its
projections of kovat nineteen's UK
mortality from 250,000 to under 20,000
roughly the same as annual deaths from
seasonal flu no one knows yet for sure
but evidence abounds that the lethality
of this virus may be in line with flus
1% and possibly as low as 0.1 percent
the disease overwhelmingly Fell's the
elderly with often multiple
comorbidities I don't mean old people
don't matter but absent this pandemic a
large portion of this ailing cohort
would have been sadly slain by other
illnesses in short order as dr. john lee
noted in The Spectator last week two
fatality figures failed to distinguish
dying from kovat and merely dying with
it pray to simplistic sentimentality
politicians loathe to land on the wrong
side of the bogus money versus people
debate could keep economies in the dead
zone for months on end through the
summer or even until the mass
dissemination of that mythical vaccine
in say 2022 unremitting better safe than
sorry policies could transform life as
we know it for years to come and not in
an improving direction we're anything
but safe right now and the longer these
lock downs continue the more imperiled
we and our descendants become we're
flirting not merely with recession we
should be so lucky but with a
potentially self-sustaining depression
with all the social services decay
cultural malaise personal desperation
and generational aimlessness that would
entail forgive my further self-promotion
to follow but my latest novel is
released in early May and we might as
well bury those hardbacks in my back
garden of course in converting to years
work to compost I have company or
companies I should say many of which
will go to the wall after proprietors
sank not a mere two years but sometimes
their whole line
into these labors of love my 2016 near
future novel the mandibles portrays the
United States in economic freefall
Russia China and Friends contrived a
currency to rival the dollar in
retaliation the American president
defaults in the eye-popping national
debt naturally the markets tanked
no one lends money to deadbeat so the US
government is denied access to borrowing
the Fed runs the printing press over
time inflation soars first supermarkets
shelves are bare clairvoyance the first
commodity to disappear is toilet roll
and police are positioned in every aisle
then the shelves are full but no one can
afford to buy a $300 cabbage DC
nationalizes gold sending the army
banging on doors searching for wedding
rings meanwhile more people are
unemployed than in work muggings are
rife and my characters are cast from
their house at gunpoint
indeed this pro-gun control author had
no choice but to secure her beguiling 16
year old protagonist a revolver
Farfetch'd public borrowing is set to
skyrocket central banks will be tempted
by the ugly shortcut of moderating
sovereign debt through money printing
hello inflation as well as confessed
guitry tax rates because a prolonged
shutdown could eviscerate the tax base
while UK firms self isolate many of
their customers will turn to China the
deserters won't likely come back and a
broke society is a violent Society look
at the unrest already arising in Italy
you think not being able to go to the
gym now is the bad part no how about
what Jim how about why would I pay for a
gym when I can't afford a litre of milk
or sod the gym I'll not go anywhere only
to get knifed in the street never in the
history of the world have most major
economies simultaneously closed shop for
months on end I've rarely been this
shaken and not because I'm afraid of
getting sick that was Lionel Shriver
next is Isabelle Hartman I thought of
her last week when I saw hens on sale in
their mirror local supermarket Isabelle
used to keep hens and I thought you
might like to write some words of advice
to anybody tempted to stockpile them now
notes on hens by Isabelle Hardman is
there nothing people won't panic by
during this crisis having stripped
shells of food and toilet roll shoppers
are now turning to chickens coop company
homeless reports a 66% rise in sales and
breeders have sold out of pullets
the British hen Welfare Trust which
rehomed caged hens has stopped taking
new customers out of fear that the
people bidding for their birds were
either planning to eat them or didn't
really know how to look after them
keeping chickens does seem like a really
good way of avoiding going to the shops
a good layer will give you an egg almost
every day at this time of year and
having a flock in your back garden will
mean you'll never run out your
breakfasts will use eggs still warm from
the hens bottom so fresh they poach
beautifully the yolks of happy healthy
hens are a rich gold that's nearly
impossible to find in the supermarkets I
have my own four hens for a few years
and I miss them terribly to the extent
that they often flutter through my
dreams I would watch for hours as they
scratched around looking for worms and
worked their way around their complex
social order hands aren't the brightest
of birds but they learn to associate
certain objects with good news whenever
I appeared carrying a green plastic bowl
they knew I was bringing porridge and
would charge towards me once they had
the bowl there was little restraint the
birds would often dunk their entire
heads in the food emerging with gloopy
oatmeal on their bright red combs the
loveliest spectacle was when the hens
took a dust bath
this ritual keeps their feathers clean
and free of parasites they would scratch
and pick out a hollow in the ground and
then settle their fluffy bodies into it
and kick the dirt over themselves they
often took these spar breaks in pairs
lying contentedly by one another and
bathing with a huh falafel thud of
feathers and claws working the soil into
their plumage
seeing them this happy made it
impossible for me to buy eggs from caged
hens or indeed those kept in barns which
is a misleading term for a massive shed
full of thousands of birds wading around
in their own feces yet I won't be
rushing to stock my garden with hens
again they need more space than the runs
supply with most commercial coops these
are really just holding pens and that
means you need to surrender a large
section of your garden or the whole
thing to destruction
they will eat anything green and dig up
anything that's left your law will turn
into a brown pockmarked moonscape
they are so overjoyed by first light
that they make an infernal noise even if
you don't have a cockerel and the worst
thing was not the Foxes sniffing around
their secure run but the rats who
attracted by their feed started to
burrow under the coop alongside those
lovely hazy dreams of my birds I also
have regular nightmares about the squeal
of rodents at dusk
ticking keeping will be bliss during
lockdown you'd have all the time in the
world to clean out the coop entertain
the birds and make sure they were out of
harm's way
but at some point our lives will return
to normal then you might find that much
like the lifetime supply of toilet roll
clogging up your house panic buying
poultry wasn't quite as smart as it
seemed that was Isabelle Hardman and
that's it for this week's audio montage
of no idea what you call this podcast
but I'd love to know what you think of
it this is a a format we're playing with
we always love to hear from you
especially in these isolated times so
please do email any thoughts to podcasts
at spectator dot co dot uk'
thanks for listening thanks for
subscribing and thanks to Cindy you
[Music]